part four per post those an intro
I guess best intro ever we actually
progress now we were doing pretty
[ __ ] well I me six to myself I'm
gonna close this door
why [ __ ] like to backstab me you know
oh it just looks excellent press 5 oh
there's different name types flash banks
whoa okay why did we just do oh god oh
god oh god oh god all you're kidding me
they got smoking [ __ ] they got a picture
shrub smoke ah later oh no ash love
schmuck scared ah
I wasn't slow man I still died you need
to save me bro
I'm Pro profess to you you better their
professed [ __ ] yup herp derp I'm serving
your look No thank you give you
proficient oh come on
brofist not good not good not good at
all bad after you shield
I'm your shield good good I got one I
think I don't know one you better
wicked
I mean washing [ __ ] please oh god oh no
you didn't oh no you down
sweet I got ten of those don't modified
oh I need ammo
cool [ __ ] okay well gotta slide [ __ ]
die do they take me off a bomb when I
punched him well I guess that makes
sense
and like I said I see there it just
slipped Baxter he start he's dead stay
[ __ ] haunted fan our home front
what Oh what the [ __ ]
look dooshka did you see the idea he was
like oh god no there was a guy in the
back row I know I know he was messed
painting done around yes he gets all
close I'm out of here
oh [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god close the
door clangs oh just look just open it
I'm ready I'm so low I'll bet oh my god
you wasted my slaw wall why keep
fighting there that's a negative
why you so negative bro here you go
that's good keep keep I can't keep it
all fried bread on the side on the side
mister you don't good or do
that's not side you stupid pasta ah
professed purpose brofist yes
brofist
I don't know why but our bar are way
longer now than before I think we were
playing on hard before I'm not joking
something changed your face changed yeah
but that's another story bro cool story
bro I died
never mind I still suck help please
Rufus better okay
ah I got him you're too slow Adam sweet
moon dude
cool story bro Oh someone provide us
[ __ ] see [ __ ] love to backstab I did
that talk that's all did it brat I did
that you can thank me later
where did you get that right it was for
his bat good for all right one open the
door whoa
I did that creepy door scooping you mail
all wrong we can go this way by the way
I should but I want a damn kudos for
Tristan let's go
ah can you hold one for me
no I can give you shield thank you no I
can yeah nothing on them oh god mom
where it exploded that's what she said
actually can you save me brofist thank
you bro fish me rack up rack - yeah have
you ranked up yeah um not something you
come at me bro
I like nevermind
Oh brofist okay let's take this route
then bye [ __ ]
and now it's oh just weapon and pick it
up just I already have those two weapon
so really opens why didn't you just
check that instead of stack saying hey
we could go this way you had to look
like it oh I had to look like a total
[ __ ] yes
don't you death row Nate at me don't you
dare
oh wow is exploded that's gross I know
you like it oh [ __ ] you like ah bollocks
but but just doing over there [ __ ]
sorry I threw an 89th okay I'm right
beside you so screw and I'm outta ammo
hold on I need to go back yes at a gun
right next to you wait oh wait I already
have a gun they're mine stupid beauty
don't help it don't tell me it's obvious
beauty sharpish
ah he's coming over he's coming over now
he's coming over
but oh [ __ ] oh all this only have a guy
I have a gun but its weak like it's not
really again I shoot this wait he's
coming over again
I got your shield I don't have anything
I kill them for you there's two guns
laying right here see work but you never
do anything shut up I do all the stuff
but you slow almost crazy
out of ammo [ __ ] great go
Oh God ah but just don't like me to kill
the bodies ah
oh that was awesome
any that I need that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hold it it's past fitzy
fast damn Fame girl that's hot
oh there's nothing wrong
that's so many pretty I'm soon dead
butter yeah look what I got for you I
got it just for you oh thank you notice
problem hey hey
problem okay
shotgun time shield time oh wait bad
time to reload bad time to reload back
oh four oh I can heal myself when I give
you the shin oh cool I take it listen
hey I talk gosh Nate I didn't know ah
wrong controls I'm Mel lead when I was
gonna he did he did he think so
Steph I think I'll ever not prepared
gosh but just love leaves liver you know
and they love when I don't know what I
really wanna that sounded really
convincing ah [ __ ] I'm so dad I shared
with you thank you get your [ __ ] bro
damn [ __ ] nudee let me go
uh Nate
I'm dead luck help me bro bro fist me
bro trying
oh [ __ ] Rafa's brothers brothers
brothers all is best prophecy bro how do
I know that
crow shitless bro ah no I'm down come
over to me bro
[ __ ] not good bad lots of them no huh
are they are there keep forgetting my
[ __ ] slow my problem
oh that heals me you know that he's me
right you're slow my heels oh it lastly
isn't it now you know - the source no
the summer doesn't need me oh that will
excuse me please ah get cover you stupid
[ __ ]
just talking to you I have gone
I'm grabbing you and you don't when I
grab you [ __ ] I'm out of ammo
I got shotgun though you're always out
of ammo you want me to hold them for
life uh uh go into them
oh now you hold them now either I'm just
kidding I know you chill the knee or
whatever you [ __ ] get rid [ __ ]
I feel some bad ass with the shotgun I
don't think you should rush in there if
my body dies I get a newer oh yeah it's
pretty awesome I should need something
like that I should need I need something
whatever waiting for coupler look numb
alike or Pyxis blah blah blah there you
go and stuff at the time and I think
turn their mind thus nothing here I
promise
I think we need to do something here or
is this there's something underneath the
stairs
can you go no they outweigh the artists
all models
Ranka my dolls spill at this soldier
sidekick how do you know I got a - I
don't know what it is so we're not
supposed to go here I do a 360 360 there
we go
very 16 it just loved 360s well what the
[ __ ]
and hey I'm scared
Oh best I was gonna save it hey can you
open let's go steal no we I come out
we're supposed to go over here we go
then yeah where Oh God
what alright we can finish part I don't
know which part it is par for in scene
part 5